lucio quiere poner a prueba y jugar
videojuegos violentos hace a la gente
más violenta pregunto a sus amigos y
jugaban videojuegos violentos y se
habían estado en una pelea en el último
mes registró los resultados en la tabla
mostrada abajo llene la tabla para
mostrar la fracción de cada grupo de
estudiantes que han estado en una pelea
luego decida si existe una relación
entre los videojuegos violentos e
involucrarse en una pelea en los amigos
de lucio
así que veamos lo que están haciendo
aquí estudiantes que juegan videojuegos
violentos fracción que ha estado en una
pelea fracción que no estudiantes que no
juegan videojuegos violentos fracción
que ha estado en una pelea fracción que
no resolvamos la primera parte de esto
estudiantes que juegan videojuegos
violentos veamos a esos estudiantes
entonces los estudiantes que juegan
videojuegos violentos parece que elena
juega videojuegos violentos deja de
enfocarme solamente en los datos que nos
importan
así que elena
identifiquemos a toda la gente que juega
videojuegos violentos veamos esta
columna es de los videojuegos
tenemos un sí aquí
y tenemos estos dos juntos aquí
y luego tenemos otro acá
y esos son todos hay 1 2 3 4 5 personas
que juegan videojuegos violentos ahora
qué fracción de ellos ha estado en una
pelea bueno parece que uno de los cinco
ha estado en una pelea pero el resto de
ellos no han estado en una pelea
entonces podemos decir que un quinto y
déjalo escribo un quinto ha estado en
una pelea
quinto ha estado en una pelea la
fracción que no
quintos
esos son todos estos nos ellos juegan
videojuegos violentos pero no han estado
en una pelea uno dos tres cuatro cuatro
quintos
ahora los estudiantes que no juegan
videojuegos violentos son todos los
demás así que déjame ver cuántos datos
son 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
así que hay un total de 15 estudiantes y
cuántos de ellos han estado en una pelea
veamos
tenemos 1
entonces 3 de los 15 han estado en una
pelea 13 15 es la misma cosa que uno
son fracciones equivalentes y la
fracción que no bueno eso serían todos
los demás serían 12 de 15 y 4 de 5 4
así que basándonos en los datos de lucio
basándonos en los datos de lucio esta no
fue una muestra muy grande veamos sólo
encontró cinco jóvenes que jugaban
videojuegos violentos y sólo uno de
ellos estuvo en una pelea así que
nosotros no
este no es un estudio muy riguroso pero
por lo menos basándonos en sus datos
intentamos decidir si hay una relación
entre jugar videojuegos violentos y
participar en una pelea entre los amigos
de lucio
no parece que la hay parece que
relativamente aunque jueguen o no
jueguen videojuegos violentos un quinto
de ellos ha estado en una pelea en el
último mes por lo que no se aprecia
ninguna diferencia si este número fuera
no sé cuatro quintos o cinco quintos o
ya saben todos ellos entonces diría que
aunque la muestra de lucio es bastante
pequeña diría que tal vez exista una
relación bastante estrecha entre jugar
videojuegos violentos y pelear pero aquí
realmente no se ve ninguna diferencia